Đây là đối thịt sau động điều hóa không có thông số phá ban đầu
Thôi thành trong ngày mắt chỉ cho anh nè dạc bài nơi
Thôi thôi thành ngày hai
Thôi hay ở đâu
Hãy hợp là các bạn biết cái vị chỉ bán bà
Nhưng mà mình sẽ đi phá ban đầu dựa vào vị chỉ bán đầu
Nhưng ta không cho lý độ có thể bán đầu
Nào vàa sẽ đi có vị
Chỉ thử ra bên bếp không làm được tốt mà
Chúng không? Nào, có bếp để bếp có bà bỏ chủng ra có vị nữa ngay
Cô này thì muốn xe hỏi mà mình phá ban đầu là phương chỉ là đối ngoài nè
Thôi thôi, còn một cái vị hoặc thông có thể bán đầu
Thôi hồi thần đối ngoài nè dạc bán đầu
Chỉ thử ra bên bà, nó có thể bán đầu
Nào vàa đối ngoài nè dạc bán đầu
Năm粉 xấu trường của mình mà
Thôi mà một dây
Thôi là thử cú trước
Đúng không?
Cái gì đó là cái khá cơ màn thì cho mình nhé
Ui mình gà hồng 2P
Chị bây giờ, cái gì bây giờ cũng cái điều quan trọng
Để tiếp với cái này vào đây cho nó khỏi nha
Thuy bồng một dây
Ui mình gà hồng 2P nhé
Bây giờ cũng có điều quan trọng là gì?
Là chúng ta chưa biết thời điểm phá bàn đầu nằm đâu
Thì cái hoạc nhìn được kí này
Cái
Thì tìm ra như đời
Bây giờ, trong cái gì bây giờ
Chúng bài chứ
Thì tìm ra như đời
Bây giờ làm người mặt
Hồng 2P
Chúng rọng
Tìm ra cũng đưa vỡ
Cái gì mà hồng hồng ở đây là một cáiiche
Hồng nó ngọc
và chắc chắn nó đang...
tăng y lên, khá cá là đang tăng.
Đúng không?
Thì mình ở ăn game là cẩn biên nó bị chi nào.
Vẽ bữa tình một vị trí, tích dương của đang tăng.
Đúng không?
Tích dương đang tăng.
Thì nó sẽ làm ở đâu nó sẽ làm ở đây.
Tôi kêu quét.
Đây là vị trí thì mấy cái điều không?
Và đây là Pham Ando.
Và dưới kia chúng ta muốn tìm được pham Ando.
Còn đúng không?
Chúng ta muốn tìm được pham Ando.
Tìm được pham Ando.
Thì các bạn làm gì?
Đúng không?
Chúng ta phải đi xa rừng người gọi và ý mình chưa có ngang này mà mình nhau.
Nhưng các bạn biết có ngang với cục ui ra.
Nó là khoảng cái ngang một pham Ando.
Túng không?
Cái tay bằng một pham Ando.
Nó đang ngang ở đâu.
Nó đang ngang ở vị trí kinh mong.
Và có xù hướng, đi xuống.
Đúng không?
Tất là tạng thật dĩnh một pham Ando.
Vật tăng ngang ở kinh mong và đang có xùi đi xuống.
Tìm mẹp tơ, tả thì nó sẽ nảm ả ở đây.
Còn đúng không?
Đúng không?
Đây là mẹp tơ và tự điện một pham Ando.
Nang là mật kinh mong của đang có xù đi xuống.
Cái gì trong các bạn có bạn có là xói đúng không?
Chú to biết đây trên hông hông luôn.
Me tè thì đẹp tiền thương của các bạn mà thôi.
Các bạn có xói anh được gái của quay rồi.
Xói anh của quay rồi, xói anh của quay rồi rồi.
Xói anh của quay rồi rồi?
Âo của quay sẽ mạnh mấy h Raum.
Lẹp tậphy.
Xói mạnh gì của anh nữa thì lọc xói mạnh của mình.
Tìm có mài bằng chiếm yêu rồi
Hẹn gian góc, ngày xong mấy nhớ
Mằng xong, bằng bà mấy đổ
Để rồi
Từ mò
Từ mò, tìm có mấy ông mà mấy đổ
Bóa lo chiến đặt pham ảnh đầu luôn
Chứ cho, như vậy có, thì bây giờ mình thang đi được pham ảnh đầu
Pham ảnh đầu của mình như vậy, bằng
Bây trên sau
Dong đổ chỉ xó là danke sau
vì vět đưa volta thì không lọv thì chỉ
chỉΠーIn!
Dưới spezie này có nổi hảnhốc luôn luôn
Đi nhớ con hông... nhớ khu etc
Vẻnh góng Incorc 3p Đây
Chu bhiền sau
Bạn, có ddis giữ cậu